hey I want to make sure I mention
something which is that you have a
channel I do uh which I think is uh
fantastic which is uh you have your own
serus XM channel life with John Mayor
and it's a different approach because
you're not just playing your music very
little of it it bums me out when my
music comes on yeah it's based on time
of day so and I thought of this because
of the Jack track I'm not kidding but
the Riff about the Jack track got me
thinking wait a minute I know this
sounds like a forced plug but it's not I
think you have a very cool approach to
having a channel and I'm I'm eager to
check it out but tell us what it is it's
called life with John May and it is not
genre based as much as it's based on the
time of day right because when we got
into algorithms and Spotify and stuff we
kind of got trapped in this idea of
telling a computer what we want to hear
and I always say it's sort of like your
grandmother keeping track of what you
like yes and and and and they're they're
wrong a lot you know and I know you're
pulling a jack trck thing in on no no no
no I wouldn't um but I would never go
back to something crash I would never
call back a crash remark that's just not
me but you know you you go I don't know
what what I want to hear what I want to
hear and then you tell uh you know
Spotify and Spotify goes I know what you
want after this and it's the same six
seven songs and it starts to like for me
personally it was becoming
claustrophobic I'd go I'd go to the gym
I'd go I don't know give me George
Benson give me the night and it would go
got it son and then I I would know what
was coming after that and I was just
getting more and more confined in in
what I was listening to and I thought if
there was a serious Channel where every
time you turned it on the music was
synchronized to the time of day as best
as possible like at night it's super
mellow music so you can have it on in
the kitchen you can I and I do it's
great in the morning it's like drive
time music you know because when you
wake up in the morning you don't want it
it's not it's not uh you know it's not
Tom weight's time no in the morning it's
okay to hear
you know since you've been gone and you
you might not play that you might not
think to tell Spotify to play that but
when it comes on at 7 in the morning and
you're in traffic it's like right on
right on it's great it's like a cup of
coffee you know what's programmed at
10:00
a.m. dead
air I'll be back in 7 minutes we're
going to take a quick break for between
uh 7 and 11 minutes we're going to let
dead air speak for itself I'll be right
back slightly out of breath and ready to
play you some Pearl Jam
be right back after I find that Sports
Illustrated with Kathy
Ireland from 1992 what is it throwback
it's throwback Tuesday it's throwback
Tuesday so that would be Cathy Ireland
Sports Illustrated we're going to be
that's so
funny it's throw back you hear me
opening a
safe I like the idea your hardcore porn
is strewn out and about throughout the
house first of all it's notl it's not
online it's but in a safe you put on
white cotton gloves is in itself a weird
obacle three to the
right hello Miss Ireland It's like got
you got the blue booties on hyper
bearing room it's like the curation room
of the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame no fluorescent
lighting I love the burglar that come to
my house and bust open the safe they
take the safe out of the wall and then
they get it back to with their layer and
they crack it open what the hell is this
they follow you home and hold you at
gunpoint to open the safe and you
finally open it up and Club magazines
come cascading
out these are all very attractive women
from the late 80s and early
90s this is a print out of Samantha
Fox half of these are
[Laughter]
articles the best VCRs of
1988 you you actually printed the
article on most poisonous
snakes there was always one
article the deadliest snakes and every
now and then I'm getting aroused by
that wow an interview with the John 316
guy from the baseball
games where's Conan someone mentioned
Egyptian ASP and he just he dashed off
he said he'd be back in s to 11 minutes
oh my God oh my God well this I mean
first of all I'm I'm very happy you're
doing this Channel and and you're you're
going to be like taking calls you're
going to be talking to people because
yeah I I go live I take calls ideally
I'd like to do interviews with people uh
if you think I'm any good you're I would
no but I would love to I mean this this
has been an absolute blast and I would
happily anytime you want me come up come
by yeah I'd love bring a guitar we'll do
we'll do buckets I actually mean it I
actually mean it you're the most
encouraging
person I've ever seen during a
conversation do you are do you are you
aware that you give constant kinetic
kinesthetic encouragement I I'm loving
this this is one of my favorite episodes
we've ever done I look over to you and
this is if everyone in the crowd were
doing what you were doing why do you
think coning keeps him around you're
fusive it's C you the thing is everyone
else everyone else here uh yeah everyone
else here uh Cuts me down and and bla is
always telling me that was amazing even
when it wasn't no it's great it is
amazing this so good it makes me feel so
good honest to God um no I uh I would be
thrilled honored to to come by and uh
and hang um and I would not I just have
to ask you one does one question been in
the back of my mind it's doesn't relate
to any of this this is not the
place this is neither the time or the
place questions but seriously I'm
thinking to myself I get this way around
people that I uh comedy gods that I
idolize and I'm thinking if you're
opening for the Rolling Stones do you
not leave does your do you not leave
your body and look at yourself doing it
and go H this isn't real do you have
that moment or do you get to a thing
where you're just like no I'm opening
for the Rolling Stones it's somewhere in
between it's holy but it's also um
we
are bound by being
musicians I wouldn't say they're peers I
wouldn't put myself on that level but we
both love the same things right right we
both stand at the same altar when we
play to the same things MH and so at
some point I have to assume that the
reason I got asked to be there was
because I was welcomed to be there sure
yeah and so I think I play better when I
go no you're supposed to be here do that
thing that you do do that thing that you
do while you're here but it never
escapes me that it's the stones so I try
not to to be intimidated and especially
now that I've played with so many great
artists and had really great
conversations with so many great artists
even just like practicing asking
questions I only wanted to answer
questions till I was like 40 right I was
only interested in hitting the balls
right and now I'm actually like I've he
I've heard every thought I have
I've heard every thought I'm pretty
familiar with my take I'm way more
interested in getting someone else to a
place they didn't know that they were
going to get to and also curiosity I
think curiosity is the big engine that
it's a n curiosity is a nuclear engine
and I think the thing that has helped me
in my life more than in my career anyway
is that I am I want to know like oh cool
John mayor's coming I'm I I want to I I
want to open up the top of his head and
let's play you know like that's really
fun and uh I think it's possible to lose
that and I've been very fortunate that I
I haven't lost my I just want to know
like what's up what's up with this
person what's going on and let's talk
yeah again I never saw it as scoring
points to hear great answers right until
I became older yeah I just wanted to be
in the batting cage right and I think I
just stopped being curious about myself
right and and and I'll meet people who
are 22 and 23 that other people will
call obnoxious and I won't be so fast to
call them obnoxious I'll be like they're
just hearing themselves play for the
first time they just got out of college
or they just wrote their first big thing
they're they're hearing every note they
can play I'm pretty familiar with my
thoughts something changed where
interesting thoughts from other people
that I know I had something to do with
extracting or even at it at its best
someone coming up with how they feel y
um that to me now is way more fun than
me investigating how I might feel about
something and I've just been practicing
the last three years without really
knowing it I mean isn't there something
fun about being at a table at a dinner
party
and being the kind of not not the host
of it but the sort of spiritual designer
of this great conversation where the
other half of the table's like what's
going on over there and you're not
talking the most but you are providing
the most in terms of getting everyone
else to come out because the best
conversations at dinner parties it's all
happening in the middle yeah it's h it's
all taking place in the middle so those
things really interest me and I'd like
to get to the point I think I just need
to do one really good interview and
other people would maybe hear I I'm
already down on myself about whether or
not anyone would want to do it because
it's so new for me oh would not worry
about I wouldn't worry about that at all
like I just anyone listening to this
podcast will be happy to hear you
chatter away and ask questions and
because you're uh really funny you're
really and you've always been you've
always been really funny but also I
think uh people as I said being around
kicking around the planet for a while is
a great bomb it's a great uh it's it's
great for us to marinate and to because
this be I am less judgmental very I was
always curious but I'm less judgmental
and I just kind of uh and and and I kind
of want to know what's happening with
other people and that those are nice
qualities and I I think you'll kill it I
think you're going to do a great job I
wouldn't worry about it I you I was
thinking I've survived every scary
thought I've ever had in my life I've
survived it I've woken up the next day
right and I've survived everything I
thought was going to kill me and so now
and I got to a place where I feel like
there's this trust in what I do with
people that if I put a record out a year
two years three years from now people
will go oh I want to hear what he has to
say yeah so everything feels so set in a
in a way that makes me feel like it's
this until a doctor sits me down and
says you know when I first got into
medicine I oh boy you know whatever that
conversation is someday where I'm told I
can't stay y That's the end of it but
until then it's don't you feel like this
is the straightaway now this is the best
oh I'm I'm I like this part better than
any other part this you you did all the
work to get here right to where you can
hire actors to hang out outside they're
all we once you got into this building I
didn't want to pay for them the whole
time they're eating across the street
gone yeah and and they're not being paid
for that time but the minute you leave
they're all going to rush back I
actually have one guy in the corner
sawing something and there's no reason
for a guy to be sawing something in a
podcast you gu dressed like an Oompa
looma who's the man who's the man with
the measuring tape who's just going
around measuring everything and also why
did I make it look like an off trck
betting
place and here comes lucky Lindy in the
[Applause]
straightaway